Colleen Ballinger finally responds to
allegations but in the worst way
possible so her lawyers say she didn't
wear black face which we know uh her
Sings tour has been canceled her career
abovely abruptly stalled and when
reached for comment Ballinger's lawyers
replied in an email that vanity Fair's
inquiries were simply a regurgitation of
the baseless and unsubstantiated claims
of other media outlets and individuals
on social media have reported the
reality of some of these claims in turn
the broader narrative around Ballinger
remains murky various allegations remain
unverified left to endlessly circulate
as they fall under the ever-expanding
umbrella of inappropriate behavior okay
stop once again her lawyers have come
out against two specific points only
blackface and the copyright thing all
the other stuff mum's the word that's
interesting or a super super vague about
everything it's baseless and
unsubstantiated like are you gonna talk
about specific claims or no because if
not we're not listening